my parents make me so mad sometimes just
like the time they couldn't
decide who gets the dog so they just
dropped off the local synagogue i was
like
oh say what
hold on ron hold that thought just for a
sec
hey honey hey
uh it's your me it's wife
it's leslie uh nope i have very big news
for you oh well my teeth are blue
blueberries
are you having a stroke i just ain't
around that my dog's jewish
oh
phone water ben
hello
oh hello
hi
leslie it's dead
hello
you know leslie sounded weird i don't
want to wait for tom i want to walk home
i'll join you i'm always game for a
brisk walk
also if i leave you alone i'm pretty
sure you'll die
home is that way
watch out for that fence watch out for
those riding lawn mowers man
[Laughter]
you were killing it i am right yes see
just thinking i'm a congressman makes me
feel like one yeah oh also i have a
little secret
i'm drunk i am too
ever since we had our kids it only takes
like one sip of wine i feel so good and
condiment
con
i feel condifent
you know what you should do you should
give a toast
because if you were running for congress
you have to give speeches right you want
me to make a toast i'll toast it up
toast it baby roast and toast it till's
brown on both sides you know what i had
my time no i did my thing i want to be
city counselor and i did and i was and i
i was like
and people were like
at least we have each other i love you
so much i love you too
this is real i know you're my husband
you're my wife you married me in front
of people i did i was there we may have
peace but it doesn't matter we need to
do something big you know something that
really lets people know that we're gonna
love each other forever yeah what is it
i got it hello sir we're sober we would
like to get tattoos in our bodies
because we love each other tattoos this
is a pawn shop
but yeah sure i can do that
[Applause]
look what he's doing he's breaking pens
this is the idea
of the century right here ow
come here
oh man this wine bottle is all out of
the wine oh hello gentlemen
what brings you out on this fine evening
mother
whoa where'd you come from uh that's a
complicated question all depends on
whether your conception of time is
linear or
circular
what
hello ron
ron you know this hobo he was my
counterpart from the eagleton parks
department dude are you a ghost am i
what is happening right now
hey everybody i'm ben wyatt listen we of
course are here to celebrate donna and
joe and i have to say you know getting
married is the bravest most wonderful
thing you can do because every day you
come home and you're just like
what
it's you i love you you're my sexy
roommate we love each other
you're talking about me yes i am baby
doll look
don and joe
are great you all
are
great and this wedding is gonna be
amazing let's get some music and dancing
going
and i am ben wyatt and i very much
approve this message
[Applause]
you want me to shut that down
no i like it
let the little man dance hey
can i ask you a question are we the
cutest couple you've ever seen nope
okay you want the long needle or the
short nail doesn't matter can't find a
shortening a long needle it is i have a
big idea i want
a portrait of eleanor roosevelt
tastefully done and then she has a very
classy tattoo of pat benatar in her arm
and that's very subtle no scratch that
scratch all that just right ben you have
anything to numb the pain sure take a
scoop out of peel bucket
okay you said you wanted mouth queen no
stop stop it stop everything that you're
doing stop it ann's here and wants to
tattoo
no no
no
[Music]
ann does not want to tattoo no one wants
a tattoo and
relax be respitable for a second okay
what we're doing is not nuts we are
merely getting tattoos so that everybody
knows we love each other and that we
haven't peeked it makes a lot of sense
okay we're leaving all right so say
goodbye to the nice man and thank me for
saving you from being on dateline okay
let's go goodbye world travel later bro
heisen ben
come on is this everybody ann took a cab
tom's in the trunk jerry's on the roof
all right where to first
your mother's butt
[Laughter]
i'm so alone
if even one of you thinks about dry
heaven in my car you're all walking home
mr rondon
i have something i'm very angry about
but other ron he's
not helping me with it can you help well
i can tell by the indigo on your
chicklets that you've been drinking
blueberry wine
that's a good start a wamapoke called it
matapiqua
they believed it had mystical powers
yeah it also tastes like jelly
so what's got your goat there friend my
parents they had this lake house and
they sold it without telling me and so i
was like why you know
i was like
god you guys oh you're hanging on to
that anger for dear life compadre
let's role play ben
what is the first rule of the leslie
knope emotional support task force
don't let her get a tattoo what the hell
happened i couldn't help it she's so
cute when she's coming up with
destructive ideas
never send a husband to do a best
friend's job out wyatt walk it off walk
it off fine
you did it yep see you later in no nope
sit down
it was beautiful
you're surrendering to the earth's
mother now stare into the fire and
picture your spirit animal well i don't
know what my spirit animal is because it
doesn't exist because that's nonsense
because you're an adult
baby snow owl
that's right our spirit animals connect
us to the natural world
you need to remain open to their message
watch
welcome back old friend
wow
if you really want to cleanse yourself
of that anger
take that check and send it into the
flames and up into the air with your
screams do not burn that check it is
money no ron's right
[Applause]
hello right baby snow
you're safe now
i feel great i ran 5k this morning
really no i threw up in the shower
you